Nein das machen wir heute wirklich.
Zumindest den i3 Nachbau für Windows ausprobieren.
Sag zumindest die GitHub Seite.
Ob das taugt?
Ich habe da ja so ein bisschen meine Zweifel ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wir werden es sehen.
Ich werde das mal package update machen.
Wobei wir brauchen die Links vor allem gar nicht.
Egal.
Package update.
Arch by the way.
Package update kann man nicht genug machen.
Aha.
Neue Version.
Aha! Neue Version!
Ich glaube ich muss die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen.
Zack!
Excellent!
Hört sich nicht ein.
Oh!
Jetzt kann man das auch wieder eins-hoben machen.
Wollte gerade sagen, warum ist es so kacke eingestellt.
Die Einstellungen sucken heute mal.
Massive!
So!
Also!
Was brauchen wir dafür?
Wir brauchen eine Windows-VM.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir noch eine haben.
Fürchte nicht.
Den Gremble kann ich auch mal löschen, oder?
Mit dem Proxmox Cluster, den brauchen wir doch niemals wieder.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich den überhaupt noch drauf habe.
Haben Services unter Linux Root nicht zwangsläufig?
Ne!
Kommt auf den Service an.
Init hat Root, potenziell.
Aber, ähm, die Services selbst nicht unbedingt.
Du kannst einstellen, mit welchem User die gestartet werden soll.
Und am besten lässt du die natürlich, wenn es nicht sein muss, nicht als Root laufen.
Und wenn es sein muss, kannst du es als Root starten und dann Privileges droppen.
Ja!
Korrekt!
Ähm, wieso kein Service?
Das funktioniert theoretisch auch.
Man könnte, man könnte ein...
...weil da brauchst du kein Service, nimmst du nur ein Startup-Skript oder so.
Könnte ein Startup-Skript bauen, das...
...updatet, wenn man das will.
Ja, doch, das würde funktionieren.
Aber will ich nicht, weil ich will ja sehen, was er macht.
Passwort-Leak.
Hier kommt nicht drauf, was mein Passwort ist.
Ist nicht erratbar.
Was ist I3? Das hier.
Das, was ihr hier gerade unter Linux seht, ist I3.
Mein...
Ein Tiling-Window-Manager.
Und da habe ich letztens was gefunden.
Auf...
...Shit-Hub.
Und zwar...
...wollte ich das heute mal mit euch outlinen.
Das da.
Das wollte ich heute mal ausprobieren.
Guck mal.
Das ist ein I3-Nachbau.
Für Windows.
Und ich bin echt gespannt, ob das so gut funktioniert,
wie es da aussieht.
Ich habe meine Zweifel.
Ich habe wirklich meine Zweifel, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Aber...
Nachdem ich natürlich nicht mein...
...mein Host-Betriebssystem damit versauen will.
Brauchen wir schnell eine Windows-VM.
Ist ja kein Ding.
Dauert eine Viertelstunde, dann ist das Ding da.
Warum ist das illegal?
Service-Ungleich-Startup-Script.
Das sind analoge Begriffe.
Ne, nicht unbedingt.
Service ist für mich früher was unter init.
Beziehungsweise jetzt halt als
Unit-File für Systemd.
Und du kannst entweder
mit Systemd
einzelne Scripts aufrufen.
Zum Beispiel gibt es ja immer noch einen Hook für
wie hieß das früher?
ETC-RC-Local, glaube ich.
Oder
du lässt es ins Skript laufen, wenn du dich einloggst.
Oder wenn dein Window-Manager startet.
Oder wann auch immer du willst.
Ja.
Aber Startup-Script und Service ist nicht zwangsläufig das Gleiche.
Sowas darf es nicht geben.
Warum?
Mit welchem Framework sollte man heute...
Und das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Da werde ich gleich was zu sagen.
Nachdem ich mich zum 50. Mal
vertippt habe.
Bei 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, wie auch immer man das schafft.
Jetzt nochmal Rebooten in der Hoffnung,
dass es alles updatet.
Mit welchem Framework
sollte man heutzutage
eine GUI-App für Windows?
Okay, es muss...
Du willst auf gar keinen Fall Cross-Plattform, richtig?
Für Windows schreiben, wenn es keine
Interessent-Web-App sein soll.
Windows Forms zu alt.
UWP tot.
WinUI 3 zu jung.
Und kinky.net Maui dead.
Ja!
Du hast das Problem von Windows-UI
gut zusammengefasst.
Man denkt echt, Microsoft leckt
Critical Information.
Also wahrscheinlich
ist dein Best-Bet trotzdem
WinUI 3.
Weil Maui willst du dir nicht geben.
Und WPF
ist auch ziemlich outdated.
Was man an vielen Stellen merkt.
Siehst du zum Beispiel daran,
wenn du versuchst neue Fonts zu verwenden
oder Color Emojis oder irgendwas.
Dann geht das so ohne weiteres nicht in WPF.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das Beste, was du machen kannst
doch tatsächlich eine
wie heißt das? Unpackaged.
Heißt das Unpackaged?
WinUI 3 App.
Alternativ,
du kannst natürlich auch
eines der anderen Cross-Plattform
UI-Technologien verwenden
und es einfach nicht Cross-Plattform machen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Du kannst natürlich, wenn du auf C++ stehst,
sowas wie Qt verwenden.
Was finde ich zumindest,
der erträglichste Part ist
Qt ist erträglich, C++ nicht.
Du kannst auch, wenn es
ein bisschen was moderneres sein darf
und du keine tiefgreifende
Integration brauchst, sowas wie Flutter
auf dem Desktop verwenden. Wobei ich, naja,
ganz ehrlich, Flutter, ich weiß nicht.
Oder du machst, was
alle machen, die
bisschen
abgefuckt sind von Microsoft und UI
und sie sharp verwenden wollen.
Nehmen Avalonia.
Probier mal Avalonia aus.
Das ist quasi Cross-Plattform WPF.
Die bieten, glaube ich, mittlerweile
sogar ein Paid-Produkt an.
Boschi, danke für den Sub.
Die bieten mittlerweile, glaube ich, gerade sogar
ein Paid-Produkt an,
wo man WPF-Anwendungen
konvertieren kann in Cross-Plattform-
Anwendungen.
Wie gesagt, guck dir Avalonia an.
Also, wenn du
auf diesen
WPF, UWP,
WinUI-Style
GUI-Sache stehst,
dann ist
Avalonia wahrscheinlich das Beste.
Das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich mag diese
XML-Geschichte nicht so sehr,
was das angeht.
Wenn ich irgendwas Kleines mache,
ist es meistens Windows Forms.
Aber
wenn es Windows sein muss,
weil das schön schnell geht, sieht halt hässlich wie die Nacht aus.
Ja, Avalonia taugt.
Du kannst natürlich auch
Elektronen oder sowas machen, wobei, ich weiß ja nicht,
wenn du willst, dass dein
Hello World 450 MB RAM verbraucht.
Wie gesagt, Microsoft und
UI, die kriegen es nicht geschissen.
Die letzten 15 Jahre schon nicht mehr.
Von wann ist WPF? WPF war
der letzte sinnvolle, gute
Versuch von Microsoft.
Das WAG ist kein G-Bait, ist kein G-Bait.
Guck, wir probieren heute
das hier aus. Schau mal.
I3 für Windows. Oder zumindest
ein I3-Nachbau für Windows.
Das hat keiner cross-compiled
für Windows. Geht Discord
aktuell. Also vor einer Viertelstunde ging's noch.
Forschi, danke für den Sub.
Hast du in deinem Vorstellungsgespräch erzählt,
dass du Archlinux-User bist?
Also ich hatte ja, als ich
wechseln wollte, ich hatte ja insgesamt
zweieinhalb Vorstellungsgespräche.
Das eine in Würzburg und das andere
in Frankfurt. Und ich glaube,
bei dem Vorstellungsgespräch
in Würzburg, da habe ich
das glaube ich tatsächlich
erzählt, weil da hatte ich so ein Treffen mit
dem Team und da waren die Leute dabei,
die dort arbeiten und da hatten wir es auch von
welche Distribution mag man?
Und da habe ich natürlich den Arch-By-The-Way-Witz gebracht.
Ich glaube,
hier in Frankfurt, im
Vorstellungsgespräch habe ich es nicht erzählt,
weil da war
einer vom Personal dabei, der hätte damit nichts anfangen
können und mein Chef,
da war ich mir da nicht sicher, ob er damit was anfangen
könnte. Deswegen habe ich da kein Archlinux-Witz
drüber gemacht.
Frage an Chat und Streamer.
Ich habe einen neuen Laptop, Ubuntu erstmal
drauf und sehe, ich bekomme in unregelmäßigen
Abständen einen Blackscreen für eine Sekunde
wie Trace.
X oder Wayland? Da geht
es schon los. Das Ja des Linux-Desktops
ist hier. Wahrscheinlich Wayland.
Im Zweifelsfall
Wayland, wenn du Blackscreens kriegst.
Siehste?
Wusste ich doch. Wusste ich doch,
dass du Wayland verwendest.
Tja.
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich, ja, ich sehe
es auch so, dass Wayland wahrscheinlich die Zukunft
ist, weil niemand an X weiterbaut.
Aber
so viel Shit
drinne noch, man.
Die kriegen seit Jahrzehnten auch schon nicht geschissen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, dass Wayland
super neu ist.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
wo wir das erste Mal ausprobiert haben
vor ein paar Jahren und ich dachte,
Moment, ist das im Stream?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Jetzt muss ich gucken, ob das im Archiv ist.
Es kann sein,
dass es das noch nicht gab.
Hier, Wayland
Guck mal, da haben wir sogar
noch ein Clip.
Weiß ich nicht.
So und zumindest in diesem
Stream, wo wir das
ausprobiert haben, war
ich kann es, ich glaube,
das ist gar nicht.
Den Stream haben wir gar nicht.
Doch, hier ist er.
Das war
2017.
Das ist 5 Jahre her.
Da wurde auch schon erzählt, Wayland,
beste und so. Und da gab es das Problem,
dass
Fenster
nicht regesized sind.
Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich das finde jetzt, aber das sind Fenster
einfach nicht resized.
Das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, Alter,
das ist ja wirklich so, die Basics der Basics
funktionierten damals einfach nicht.
Fenster haben, also wenn ich
Fenster resized habe, sah das
so aus. Okay, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
So sah das aus, als ich Fenster resized
habe in Wayland.
Also, das Fenster
ist, der Content ist nicht resized,
sondern es
wurde gesoomt und der Content ist
gleich geblieben.
Das ist doch richtig kaputt,
Mann. So, wir müssen übrigens
gerade bei der Gelegenheit, habe ich noch eine
Windows ISO hier rumliegen, vielleicht?
Äh, kurz
Größe gucken.
Alter, warum ist eigentlich
nichts zu gebrauchen in Windows?
Wirklich gar nichts.
Popliches Sortieren
nach Size
funktioniert nicht, Mann.
Alter! Was ist das?
Kann man das nicht einfach
überhaupt
nicht croupen? Ich will es nicht croupen.
Nein, okay.
Okay, ich habe
kein Windows 11 ISO.
Ja, das ist Layer
11, aber es ist auch unglaublich bescheuert
gemacht.
So, Windows 11 ISO.
Hersteller. Runterladen.
Warum kann man eigentlich ein ISO für Windows
11 runterladen, aber
nicht für Windows 10?
Versteht das
irgendjemand?
Also, man kann mit
Trick 17 natürlich auch eins runterladen für Windows
10. Lädt das jetzt?
Ah ja, es lädt.
Alter, wie lahm ist denn das?
Warum ist das so langsam?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Konnte man
hier nicht mal...
Also, mich regt diese Funktionsreduzierung
unglaublich auf.
Adresse des Links kopieren,
das will ich haben. Überall wird
irgendwas rausgekürzt, weil sie sich
irgendwie denken, ach nee, das könnte die
Oma verwirren, wenn sie Chrome verwendet. Das geht
nicht, dass da ein extra Button ist.
Ich habe keinen Downloadmanager
installiert. Brauche einen ordentlichen
Downloadmanager. Chrome
bekommt
es halt auf die Reihe, Windows
ISO
runterzuladen.
Wie ging das jetzt?
Minus J
oder so? Minus 15 oder
so? Nee, oder minus X?
Minus X?
Ah, Mann, ähm...
Minus... Hä, habe ich doch
gemacht? Ah, war das minus klein J?
Oder war es vielleicht auch minus klein X?
Zack, bumm, schon gleich viel
schneller, guck, zwei Minuten.
Wir müssen Windows mit Linux runterladen, dann ist
es schneller, als wenn wir Windows mit Windows runterladen.
Easy. Zack, bumm.
Easy. It's
easy.
Um nicht zu sagen...
Easy as fuck.
Man muss, man muss
Windows mit Linux runterladen.
Ja, aber es gab auch zu Windows
10 Zeiten kein
ISO-Download. Schickt mal einen Link
zum Repo, habe ich doch hier gezeigt gerade.
Das da, Glace
VM.
Zumindest ein
i3-inspirierter Window-Manager
für Windows. Bin echt mal
gespannt, ob das... Nein, nein, nein.
Jetzt fängt es nochmal an, runterzuladen.
Geht doch nicht rum.
Nein. Exit.
Runterladen, gut ist.
Ja.
Hackermans hier wieder im Stream.
Ja, man konnte auch,
was auch geht, man konnte auch mit
Windows einfach den
Mobilmodus im Browser aktivieren.
Also man kann ja hier, wenn man
in...
Also, ich kann es euch einfach zeigen.
Ja, guck. Windows 10
Download. Man konnte auf die Windows
10 Download-Seite gehen.
Ja, da steht immer ISO-File, aber es gibt kein
ISO-File. Na gut, ging man hier auf
Inspect und hat gesagt
ähm
Mobile. Und dann konnte
man, guck, ISO runterladen,
Windows 10. Man musste den Mobile
View anmachen und ihr seht, jetzt kann
man Windows 10 ISO runterladen.
Also, man weiß nicht, was mit
Microsoft abgeht, warum das vorher nicht auch
geht. Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt,
dass das noch so wenige kennen.
Aber es geht. Guck, und wenn ihr nicht mit
Mobildings draufgeht, dann
bietet euch das ISO nicht an.
Microsoft-Logik, ja?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist komplett
Das ist komplett auf Windows.
Also, das hat Windows ja
tatsächlich echt vorne raus.
Die haben einfach eine Grafikausgabe
oder, ja, so ein
Composite-Window-Gedöns-Layer
dazwischen, der halt
funktioniert.
Und die müssen sich nicht
mit X oder Wayland oder sowas rumschlagen.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal,
weil ich ja aus Linux
Windows runtergeladen hab,
weil es schneller war als aus Windows,
müssen wir erstmal
Hallo? Windows?
Windows? Windows, ich würde
gerne das ISO hier rauskopieren, wenn es
erlaubt ist.
Windows? Hallo?
Okay, jetzt geht
einfach gar nichts mehr.
Die wollen einfach nicht, dass es
schneller ist,
mit Linux Windows runterzuladen,
als mit Windows selbst.
Datei zu groß? Doch.
Doch, doch, das funktioniert.
Das habe ich schon oft gemacht.
Der Windows macht gerade wieder Faxen.
Mit Achsen.
Ja. Windows,
Windows macht Faxen. Guck mal.
Richtig, richtig dead-gear ist das.
Massive dead-gear.
Macht das überhaupt jetzt gerade was, oder?
Oh.
Vmware ist richtig am rödeln.
Ja, guck mal.
Ich bin mir da jetzt nicht so sicher, ob ich
mich trauen kann,
Vmware zu schließen, oder ob
traue ich mich,
Vmware abzuschießen?
Ach komm, wir warten mal kurz zwei Minuten.
Vielleicht kriegt es sich gleich wieder ein.
Nochmal zu der Frage von eben, wie kann ich denn
bestenfalls verfolgen, woher der Black Screen...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie du das unter Wayland
rauskriegst. Also ich wüsste es unter X auch nicht,
aber da hatte ich noch nie Black Screens.
Keine Ahnung.
Ey, was ist das denn hier schon wieder?
6 Gigabyte auf einer
SSD zu kopieren ist jetzt nicht so krasser
Shit, oder?
Gute Frage. Okay, Chat-Gear, mal in mich gehen.
Hätte ich ein Laptop und
ich würde laufen Black Screens. Ich würde
gucken, ob ich den Black Screen mit irgendwas
X-basiertem nicht habe.
Das ist das Erste, was ich ausprobieren würde,
um auszuschließen, dass es an Wayland liegt.
Und wenn es an Wayland liegt,
würde ich einfach zu Google gehen und sagen
Wayland, Notebook,
Black Screen.
So, every second.
Da würde ich
mich durch die Suchergebnisse
quälen.
Und wahrscheinlich wird dir dann irgendjemand
in irgendeinem Reddit-Post
oder Forums-Post landen,
wo du
einen User findest, der exakt das gleiche
Problem hat und der sich dann von
einem Wayland-Pro anhören muss, dass er das
falsch benutzt und das eigentlich überhaupt nicht die Schuld
von Wayland ist, dass das nicht geht.
Und fuck you, Nvidia und AMD.
Und ihr seid alle Kacke und Wayland ist das Geilste.
Und jetzt stell dich mal nicht so an.
Du solltest eigentlich froh darüber sein,
dass du es benutzen darfst und
stell dich nicht so an, dass du eine Sekunde Black Screen hast.
Sowas wirst du
dann wahrscheinlich früher oder später finden.
Okay, Leute, ich muss anscheinend echt
Forever neu starten.
Das hat's
destroyed.
Ich hoffe,
Forever startet jetzt wieder richtig.
Okay, das hat schon mal funktioniert.
Ach ja.
Ich hätte mal
meinen Download weiterlaufen
lassen sollen unter Windows, Leute.
Ach guck mal, unter Windows
ist es jetzt auch schneller. Das musst
du erst mal sehen, dass es unter
Linux schneller ist,
sodass es jetzt unter Windows auch schnell ist.
Alles klar. Ja,
wisst ihr was? Dann lösche ich das einfach
unter Linux wieder und probiere
dieses komische Track und Drop erst gar nicht aus.
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht
verkehrt, das stimmt schon. Irgendwelche Logs
gucken. Ich würde auf jeden Fall ausprobieren,
ob ich es unter X auch
habe. Kann man
Ubuntu noch mit X starten?
Ubuntu frisch installiert?
Hat es noch eine X Session?
Geht das? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Eine Session alleine
reicht ja nicht.
Obwohl ich ja auch alles installiert habe.
Obwohl Ubuntu hat noch eine X drunter.
Dann würde ich das mal tatsächlich direkt
mit X starten anstatt mit Wayland.
Übrigens,
nur mal zur Erklärung, warum ich
so eine Abneigung gegen Wayland habe.
Ich verwende ja zum Beispiel ganz gerne
hier
meine Linux-VM. Und wenn ihr jetzt mal
guckt auf GitHub, dann gibt es
wieder eine große Diskussion drüber,
dass Wayland in einer
VM nicht richtig funktioniert, weil
also das Problem ist, und ihr müsst euch
das mal vorstellen,
Wayland
refresht den Screen nicht
in einer VM. Also ihr könnt
euch vorstellen, das bedeutet, du kannst
das nicht benutzen, weil
wenn der Screen nicht refresht,
heißt das, es wird nichts angezeigt.
Der Einzige, also auch
kein Mauszeiger bewegen oder so,
das Einzige, den Screen
refresht zu bekommen, ist
zwischen
Terminal
und
GUI-Session
zu wechseln.
Dann refresht das Screen.
Man kann das Ganze überschreiben
mit einer
Software-Rendering
oder so was, Environment-Variable,
das funktioniert,
und dann geht das. Ja,
ich habe es auch gemerkt
schon, dass das mit Ubuntu-Wayland
funktioniert. Ich gehe davon aus,
dass das irgendwas
anders macht.
Als wenn man einfach nur Sway oder so
in Wayland starten will.
Es gibt aber auch Wayland
VMware
Refresh, gibt es auch ein Ticket zu.
Hier.
When will Wayland support?
Ach so, Copy-Paste funktioniert ja auch nicht,
habe ich ganz vergessen.
Copy-Paste ist ja auch kaputt mit Wayland
unter VM.
Oder ist das speziell, das ist ein
Problem, ja, das ist ein VMware-Problem.
Das Ding ist halt,
dass es mal wieder die gleiche
Scheiß-Diskussion
gibt
wie mit so vielen
Linux-Projekten.
Es wird sich jahrelang drüber
diskutiert, wer
jetzt schuld ist und wer das jetzt
implementieren muss. Die Wayland-Leute
sagen, ach nö, das machen wir nicht.
VMware ist es vollkommen egal.
Die Treiber-Hersteller interessieren das Ganze auch nicht.
Dann schieben sie sich das alle
30 Jahre
untereinander zu
und irgendwann
kommt dann mal
der CEO von Ubuntu
und stellt fest, auf seinem
Laptop funktioniert es nicht
und steckt dann 20 Millionen
rein und dann geht es auf einmal.
Das ist wirklich voll für den Arsch, was da teilweise abgeht.
Aber so ist es halt, da muss man
sich dran gewöhnen.
Das ist die gleiche Diskussion, Leute.
Erinnert sich noch, guckt mal,
jetzt mal ohne Scheiß,
was meint ihr, wie lange
geht
Hardware-Decoding von Videos auf YouTube
unter Windows schon?
Was ich damit meine ist, wie lange könnt
ihr eure Grafikkarte schon zum Videos gucken
auf YouTube verwenden unter Windows?
Also so, dass ihr nicht
80% CPU-Last auf einem Kern
habt, sondern das Ganze decoded wird
von der Grafikkarte. Wie lang geht
das schon? Das geht mindestens
seit 2013.
Mindestens
Bei meinem
vorverletzten PC ging das schon.
Wahrscheinlich eher 15 Jahre.
Wahrscheinlich geht das seit 2005 oder so.
Seit Xbox Release oder irgendwann.
2007 oder sowas schon.
Das geht seit
15 Jahren unter Windows.
Und unter Linux geht das erst seit
einem Jahr, halbwegs. Und dann
auch nur in der passenden Kombination von
Du musst das Video erwischen mit dem richtigen
Codec. Du brauchst die richtige Browser-Version.
Du brauchst die richtige Mesa-Treiber-Version.
Du brauchst die richtige Grafikkarte
und den richtigen Grafikkarten-Treiber dafür.
Und dann, wenn du Glück hast,
funktioniert's und dann brauchst du noch ein Browser-Plugin.
Was natürlich die Videos auf YouTube
Forced auf H.264
weil VP9 zwischenzeitlich
einfach mal wieder kaputt gegangen ist.
Und, ey, das ist so
für'n Arsch, man. Linux ist toll,
aber auf dem Desktop wird das nix, Leute.
Auf dem Desktop...
Es können noch so
viele Leute sagen, bald ist das
Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Die kriegen diesen ganzen Kram einfach nicht geschissen.
Ja.
Das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür immer.
So, was macht eigentlich mein Download hier?
Ah, gleich fertig. Nice.
Kann man nach ner halben Stunde anfangen.
Das ist ja doch relativ schnell für meine Verhältnisse.
Firefox sind eh die
geilsten, die einfach mal ihren
H.264-Decoder
für Android entfernt haben, random, weil's keinen Bock mehr hat.
So, ISO ist fertig,
downgeloadet. Nein.
Nein.
Nein, das hat mit HTML5 überhaupt
nix zu tun. Es geht um Hardware-Decoding,
dass die Grafikkarte die Videos decodet.
Und das ging bis vor... Das geht teilweise
in manchen Konstellationen immer noch nicht.
So, dann legen wir doch mal...
Wie viel Platz hab ich denn wo?
Hab ich auf C genug Platz?
C? Ja, locker. Easy, easy.
Jetzt ist... Jetzt kommt wieder...
Jetzt wird's wieder kompliziert, ne Windows-11-Kiste
anzulegen. Also, Forever
Workstation 17. Ja, ich mach das später.
Wir installieren Windows
11. Wir wollen
das hier unter Documents
Virtual Machine. Ja, meinetwegen. Ganz toll.
So, jetzt muss man ein
Passwort eingeben, weil ansonsten
nicht Windows
11-kompatibel. Warum auch immer.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
geht nicht. In TPM macht
der automatisch mit dem Preset mittlerweile, glaub.
UEFI, Secure Boot.
Ich glaub, Secure Boot
braucht man gar nicht mehr.
Number of Processors
1, Number of Core
6. Das ist Windows 11, braucht ein bisschen Power.
16 GB RAM
sollte reichen.
NAT, das ist
gut. NVMe ist gut.
Create new Virtual Disk.
64 GB ist auch gut.
Single File.
Windows 10, so.
Printer weg.
Es ist okay.
So, dann hängen wir
jetzt mal das ISO rein, installieren mal schnell Windows
10. Dann kann ich mich, das kann ich ja echt schon
sagen, kann ich mich bei der Windows 11, äh Windows
11 installieren, nicht Windows 10.
Kann ich mich bei der Windows 11-Installation wieder
aufregen, weil ich mir
nicht merken kann, wie man
das ohne Microsoft
Account installieren macht.
Da musste man irgendwie die Konsole öffnen und
irgendeinen Blödsinn eingeben, dass es dann funktioniert
hat.
Aber glücklicherweise ist der Chat so
high IQ, dass der Chat das immer weiß.
Der Chat sagt mir dann immer, wie das funktioniert.
Da muss man eine Konsole
aufmachen und dann muss man eingeben
irgendwie
OOB oder sowas.
Äh ne,
Internet weg ist nicht notwendig.
OOBE
bypass NRO.
Obviously muss man das machen.
Ich finde, das ist vollkommen
klar und ja, also
wer das nicht weiß, ist schon ganz schön cringe,
oder? Wem das nicht klar ist,
dass er das eingeben muss.
So, Language to install, English,
United Kingdom, Time and Currency.
Es ist eh egal, was man hier auswählt.
Keyboard, Urdu.
Ja, das ist
es, Leute. Genau, Internet
weg gibt's nämlich Probleme. Das hatte ich auch
so im Hinterkopf.
Was das gebraucht,
was Urdu, Keyboard Layout.
Wo, wo, ich weiß
noch nicht mal,
in welchem Teil, noch nicht mal auf welchem
Kontinent,
man Urdu brauchen, wahrscheinlich Afrika,
wo man das brauchen würde
als Keyboard Layout.
Warum sieht der Installer immer noch scheiße aus?
Tja, weil es
Microsoft am Arsch vorbei geht.
So, next.
Ja, ja, OOB ist
Out of Box Experience.
Die Microsoft Benamung von Dingern,
ich hab aufgegeben,
es irgendwie zu hinterfragen, warum
was wie heißt.
Für eine Firma einrichten, dann stattdessen
einer Domäne beitreten, reicht doch, um lokalen
Account zu haben. Echt?
Soll ich mal ausprobieren?
Okay, ich gucke jetzt nach, wo man Urdu
Sprache, wo spricht man Urdu.
Urdu ist die Nationalsprache
Pakistans, sowie
eine der Amtssprachen Indiens.
Ah, also quasi Peter von
Microsoft Support.
Sorry, von Microsoft
Gold Support natürlich.
Warum lädst du dir nicht die fertigen
VMs von Microsoft runter?
Gute Frage, weil ich nicht wusste, dass es welche
gibt. Wo gibt's denn welche?
Das bedeutet, Urdu ist vermutlich
das häufigste Layout.
Bestimmt eines der häufigsten, ja.
Die haben viele Leute.
Ich schick dir einen Link.
Bin mal gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Microsoft.
Microsoft.to oder so.
Ah ne, tatsächlich. Wait a minute.
Gibt's wirklich?
Da guck an.
Es ist auch
keine Fake-Adresse.
Das ist ja, dass wir gebated werden oder so.
Interessant.
Lädt der jetzt direkt runter
oder was? Hallo?
Ich hab grad geklickt, der wollte nicht
abbrechen. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Wisst ihr, ich sollte einfach
die VM behalten und mal einen Snapshot machen.
Dann wär das ganz einfach.
Aber das war mir auch neu.
In welchem Format gibt's
die eigentlich? Okay, Parallel, Switchelbox,
Hyper-V, wer auch immer sich das
gibt freiwillig und VM, ja.
Oh, dann verkehrt.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass sie das machen.
Oh, ist schon fertig. Guck mal hier.
Das ging aber richtig schnell jetzt.
Is this the right country or region?
Wir sollten tatsächlich...
Okay, das ist
okay. Jaja, yes, yes.
Beste...
Keyboard-Layout, nee.
Keyboard-Layout. Wisst ihr, was mich auch übelst
triggert? Dass man hier nicht...
Man kann nur scrollen.
Man kann hier nicht
irgendwie G drücken.
Das ist so
zusammengestückelt alles.
Elfensprache.
Skip.
Und jetzt müssen wir erstmal 50 Mal
auswählen,
dass wir nicht getrackt werden wollen.
Moment.
Leute, Moment.
Warum durfte ich installieren, ohne dass ich
einen Account eingeben muss?
Das kommt noch.
Hackwait heißt das Ding jetzt.
Warum muss man das Keyboard-Layout
auswählen, nur um dann das Keyboard-Layout auszuwählen?
Die Frage stelle ich mir auch jedes Mal.
Weil die anscheinend nicht in der Lage sind
zwischen Installer und installiertem OS
zu kommunizieren, was man für ein Keyboard-Layout
ausgewählt hat.
Kennt wer eigentlich eine gute Alternative zu CentOS?
Ja, entweder Geld für Red Hat ausgeben
oder
gibt zwei Sachen, aber die sind bei weitem
natürlich nicht so erprobt wie CentOS, weil
war bisher auch nicht notwendig.
Alma und Rocky Linux.
Weiß ich aber nicht, was zur Zeit da die
bevorzugte
Sache ist. Debian ist keine Alternative.
Es geht hier um Red Hat-Klons.
Was ist denn
Was ist denn zur Zeit
beliebte Alma-Linux oder
oder
Rocky-Linux?
Echt? Ich hab das
nicht verfolgt.
Da nehmen fünf Leute
dran teil, sonst keiner interessiert.
Was?
Okay.
Okay, irgendjemand hat doch geschrieben,
man braucht das nicht mehr. Was soll ich jetzt
machen? Setup for personal use?
Oder was soll ich machen ohne
ohne OOB-Experience
dingsen zu müssen?
For work und dann Domain.
Okay. Und jetzt?
Sign in options?
Domain
join instead.
Okay. Tag.
Next.
Kann man das Passwort nicht einfach
weglassen? Doch, nun.
Moment.
Das war's? Man muss dieses
OOB-Shit gar nicht machen?
Ja, okay.
Nein, keine Location.
Nein, kein Device.
Nein.
Nein. Okay.
Ist es weniger geworden?
Ist es weniger?
Früher kam immer an der Stelle jetzt
Hi, I'm Cortana.
Glücklicherweise ist der Shit weg.
So, und dann erstmal
Forever Tools drauf und dann
können wir es ausprobieren.
Kann Cortana sogar den's? Ich glaube
Cortana ist gar nicht mehr dabei.
Oh, doch.
Ich muss mal kurz
Cortana überfahren.
Kann man das nicht?
Muss richtig positioniert sein.
Okay.
Shit!
Cortana crapped den Fokus.
Moment, ich muss
Cortana outplayen.
Moment, moment.
Cortana muss outplayed werden. Sekunde.
Muss auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Fuck!
Leute, das Startmenü hat
hyper-super-top-Window-Fokus.
Da geht nix drüber.
Ich hab's grad vom anderen
Display getriggert. Normalerweise
rendern meine Bilder
on top über alles drüber.
Aber das Startmenü ist wahrscheinlich
so high-priority, da kann man
nicht drüber rendern.
Okay, Vm.
Install Vmware-Tools.
Wenn ich
Windows 11
schon sehe im Default-Modus,
da dreh ich immer durch.
Ja, genau, es hat
Z-Index 9 Milliarden.
Backup von der Vm als Vorlage.
Ich hab mir das überlegt.
Brauch ich doch nicht, weil
das nächste Mal ist irgendein komischer Patch von Microsoft
raus. Und dann brauche ich
länger, den Patch zu upgraden, als
neu von der ISO, der aktuellen ISO zu entziehen.
Was sind das eigentlich für komische Punkte
hier? Ist das...
Search the Solar System.
Nerv einfach nicht, Microsoft.
Mach den ganzen Scheiß einfach weg.
Was hat die höhere Priorität?
Task Manager oder...
Das ist eine gute...
gute Frage.
Man kann das nicht richtig testen,
weil der dann nicht fokussiert bleibt.
Kann man...
Always on top.
Okay, der Task Manager
hat Priorität.
Task Manager ist always on top.
GachiBass, der kennt da nix.
Wenn man in der Domain ist,
kann da das Firmen-Logo stehen.
Das fanden unsere Chefs unfassbar geil.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auf so Kleinkram, da stehen die schon.
Das finden die geil.
Search Box, Hide.
Und jetzt das
ganze Please Align
Left.
Kann man eigentlich ungroupen
schon oder ist das noch nicht raus?
Ich glaube, das ist
noch nicht raus, dass man...
Oder ist das raus?
Moment, gucken wir mal.
Ob das das ist.
Hey!
Ich meine, es ist halt maximal hässlich gemacht,
aber es funktioniert.
So, und jetzt müssen wir, ganz wichtig,
Dark Theme
Äh.
Ging das nicht auch unaktiviert?
Ich bilde mir ein,
dass Theme-Einstellungen
gingen doch auch bisher immer unaktiviert.
Naja, anscheinend nicht.
Pass mal auf, ich hab ne Idee.
Wo ist der
Co-Pilot?
Ist das mittlerweile schon drinnen?
In Windows?
Wie mach ich diesen komischen Co-Pilot
noch nicht? Ah, weil den Co-Pilot
konnte man fragen dafür.
Aber, wie dem auch sei.
So.
OM?
Moment, wo war das jetzt nochmal?
View-Exclusive-Mode. Brauch ich sonst.
Sonst spackt der rum mit
Tastenschortcuts.
Okay, als erstes, erstmal.
Geh weg!
Erstmal Firefox downloaden.
Okay, ich sehe,
der Chat ist...
Firefox download, opera.com
Ja, ist klar.
Nice Ergebnisse.
Ich will
Firefox nicht auf Deutsch runterladen.
Ich hätte gerne Firefox auf
Englisch.
Aber
Mozilla hat keinen Bock,
so wie es aussieht.
Englisch. Stimmt!
Wir haben ja Winget jetzt.
Ich vergesse das immer.
Terminal.
Winget.
Install Firefox.
Ich hab immer noch...
Wenn ich manchmal so komisches Zeug tippe,
das liegt daran,
dass ich immer noch Pflaster am Finger hab.
Äh.
Und jetzt? Jetzt ist es brocken, oder was?
Nice.
Kann da eigentlich irgend...
Und jetzt ist meine Shell auf einmal blau.
Kann da einfach irgendwas
funktionieren, man?
Okay, geht Chrome.
Das ist so eine Krücke, dieses System.
Ich glaub, wir installieren
WSL. Das ist von uns besser.
Wie kann man diesen Bullshit einfach
nur ver... Ich versteh's nicht.
Firefox download.
Na gut, man kommt halt nicht drumherum.
Warum kann ich das nicht auf Englisch bekommen?
En. Download. Ja. Beste.
Hier. Download Firefox.
WSLG
hat...
WSLG hat auch so
seine Probleme.
Warum ist Winget eigentlich jetzt auf einmal
kaputt? So mal
GitHub zum Beispiel.
Hä?
Winget...
Winget broken.
Broken Winget after installing
Windows 11 and all its updates.
Last week.
What the f...
Vielleicht geht das mit der neuen PowerShell.
Das ist doch... Achso, ja. Das ist doch
PowerShell. Okay, vielleicht...
Vielleicht liegt's auch... Vielleicht wir machen's mal
mit CMD. Winget
search Firefox.
Fox.
Ne.
Hahaha.
Oh, das ist doch schlecht alles, man.
Keine Updates available.
Okay, vielleicht...
Vielleicht muss ich updaten. Okay, okay, okay.
Vielleicht muss ich updaten.
Jetzt ist die Frage, updatet man
Winget über Windows Update oder über den Windows
Store?
Man weiß es ja nicht so genau.
Dieses Betriebssystem ist so
eine krasse Zumutung, man.
Wo seh
ich überhaupt, ob es Updates im
Store gibt? Wo seh ich das
überhaupt? Get Updates.
Hier. Okay, restart
required. Und jetzt...
Hier weiß man ja nicht, was er macht.
Microsoft ist der Meinung, dass
ein blauer Button mit
einem Spinner drauf komplett
genug Informationen sind,
dass man versteht, was hier vor sich geht, gerade.
Sagt euch auch
dieser blaue... Ah, achso, natürlich.
Jetzt ist alles klar.
Ist einfacher zu programmieren.
Alter, wie
viel kommt da bitteschön über den Store, man?
Und warum macht Windows Update
nicht automatisch ein...
Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Ist egal. Cortana! Jawoll!
Endlich! Glück! Leute!
Danke, Microsoft! Cortana
wird geupdatet und MSN Weather
und Microsoft People.
Was ist Microsoft People überhaupt?
Das ist so unsinnig,
dass du nicht mal starten
kannst im Taskmenü.
Eclipt Champ ist auch am Start, ja.
Ich warte immer noch auf
die Überweisung von Microsoft.
Dein iPhone macht doch auch
Updates separat vor. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber da macht es
auch automatisch.
Da muss ich nicht in Apps
dort klicken, den ich eh nicht benutzen will.
Ich kann kein Dark Mode
anmachen, weil ich Windows nicht aktiviert habe.
Außer Viva... Moment.
Okay, Chat geht.
Wie war noch mal?
Dark Mode aktivieren geht ohne.
Sag mal wie.
Irgendjemand hat vorhin ein Registry Hack
gepostet. Aber ich mache keine
random Registry Sachen aus dem Chat.
Was jetzt?
Was?
Ist das Tor gecrashed gerade, oder was?
Zu viele Sachen,
die sich geupdatet haben.
Gleichzeitig.
Ach, der Store hat sich
geupdatet. Ach so.
Solitär. Endlich.
Endlich.
Rechtsklicken auf dem Desktop und dann
wie man es normal anmacht. Ne, das geht
nicht mehr. Normal gehst du hier
Personalize.
Sagst
Themes.
Und dann kannst du sagen...
Moment.
Wo ist denn das
überhaupt jetzt?
Dark Theme.
Geht nicht, weil
you need to activate.
Yentari, mach meine random Registry
Sachen.
Mal gucken.
Ach, Moment.
Hä?
Da geht das?
Aber da geht das nicht.
Das ist...
Das ist so dumm.
Das ist so dumm. Das tut immer so
weh, wenn ich den Scheiß benutzen muss.
Das ist komplette
Zumutung, der Scheiß.
Das macht
einen ja fertig.
Das muss hier in die Mitte
und ein bisschen größer.
Microsoft Support eröffnet.
Ja, klar.
Hat es
jetzt eigentlich alles geupdated?
Ja, oder? Okay, ich will jetzt wissen,
was Microsoft People ist.
Guck mal, der hat Microsoft People
geupdated. Und wenn ich nach...
Wenn ich da nach suche, finde
das nicht mal.
Dafür habe ich
bestimmt wieder Disney Plus
oder so ein Shit drauf.
Ja, geht eigentlich.
Spotify, WhatsApp.
So, jetzt muss ich neu
starten, weil er sagt ja
Restart.
Das ist die Kontakte-App.
Ja, ist gut, dass die im Store Microsoft People
heißt, aber im Startmenü
sind Kontakte.
Das ist wichtig, dass man den Zusammenhang
nicht erkennt.
Kontakte. Es sind immer Kontakte, findet er bei mir.
Okay, kann ich jetzt endlich ausprobieren?
Okay, wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Wir haben es geschafft. Nice.
Checking for updates. Oh, es geht weiter.
Eben waren wir angeblich noch up-to-date.
Ach, jetzt kommen nur noch
die neuesten Virus-Definitionen.
Das ist okay, das darf.
Die Sounds sind
angenehmer. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist korrekt.
Okay, View
exclusive. Download and install.
Kommulativ update
preview. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Genug kumuliert.
Kommulativ
make primary browser. Ja.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, Glaze
WM GitHub. Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Releases. Guck mal, das letzte Release ist
vom September.
Das ist sogar relativ
neu. Zwei
Monate oder so alt.
In was ist denn das programmiert?
Hoffentlich blazingly
fast written in Rust.
Ach nee, C Sharp. Okay, dann könnte es ja tatsächlich
was taugen.
Hier, X64.
Ach, jetzt soll ich mal Winget ausprobieren.
Winget
search Firefox.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert Winget.
Ich bin aber, es ist aber geil,
dass es Windows 11 ausgeliefert
mit der Winget-Version, die einfach
komplett wrong ist.
Warum genau findet er
das bei Firefox?
Ich meine, ich finde, dass
Blaze-Floor-P-Lightning
nicht nach Firefox klingt.
Tag Firefox-Fork. Okay.
Was auch immer das ist.
Hat der Download
funktioniert?
Okay, install.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Run anyway.
My vm now.
Ähm.
Wie es einfach hinterm Fenster war.
No config file found.
At keck-glaze-wm-config-yaml.
Create new config file
yaml. Okay.
So, jetzt muss ich mir aber ein bisschen...
Hat er denn jetzt gleich gestartet?
Oder so?
Excellent, excellent.
So.
Äh.
Okay.
Das hat leider keine I3...
Shortcuts.
Da muss ich erstmal in die Shortcuts
reingucken.
Ah ja.
Zwischen Desktops. Okay.
Da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier
mal ein Terminal starten.
Okay, das ist das gleiche.
Ich kann ein Terminal starten.
Wir sollten uns mal...
Wir sollten uns mal die...
Config angucken.
Tja. Okay. Pass mal auf.
PowerShell-Skills, Leute. Jetzt kommt's.
PowerShell.
Also, cd
glaze-wm
wm-config-keckl
Ah, das gibt's ja nicht. Moment. Gibt's?
Ne.
less-config-yaml. Ach nee.
More?
Ah ja, das geht. Okay.
Können wir das nicht einfach... Okay, wir brauchen
Whistles. Okay.
winget-search
Ah ja.
Autocomplete geht natürlich nicht.
Okay.
winget-install
Was?
Das ist nicht angeklickt. Warum nicht WM?
Weil wir unter Windows sind.
Ah, die floating Dinger macht er auch
als Teil. Okay.
Ja, das macht i3 teilweise auch.
Aber ich hab's bei den meisten
Sachen, die Pop-Ups sind eingestellt
bei meinem i3, dass der das nicht macht.
Ich weiß das WM ganz gut
und der Windows funktioniert.
So. Also, code.
Ah nee. Man musste das
erst schließen. Ja, und jetzt...
Und wenn man's nochmal aufmacht, dann geht's, glaube ich.
Code. Okay, das finde ich doch
schon mal gar nicht so...
gar nicht so verkehrt.
So, wie verschiebt man das jetzt auf...
Aha. Aha. Okay, guckt.
Aber das
Switchen zwischen Desktops ist schon ein bisschen...
ein bisschen cringe.
Okay, was kann man hier einstellen?
Fokus. Nein, automatisch
Fokus ist doof.
Sekunde.
Ähm. Settings.
Äh, nee.
Config.
Chase. Ach, wie war das? Hieß das nicht Settings?
Das ist halbescheuert.
User Settings?
Ach, Preferences
hieß das. Preferences.
Und.
18.
Äh, schon besser.
20.
Ah, das ist gut. Also, ich muss
sagen, eine Sache hat Microsoft richtig
gemacht. Konsolas ist ein nicer Font.
So, also. Gaps.
Gaps machen wir schon mal ein bisschen kleiner.
Fünf reicht. Und Outer Gap. Fünf reicht
auch. Also, das ist quasi ein Gap
zwischen den Fenstern und ein Gap
außenrum. Fünf reicht.
Äh, gibt es sowas wie Reload?
Aha. Okay. Nice.
Er hat, er hat so eine Art
I3-Keybindings. Da kann man
nur mit Alt anstatt mit Windows-Taste.
Was
glaube ich unter Windows
gar nicht so verkehrt ist.
Kann mir Bing da helfen, so?
Ne.
VS Code will links unten updaten.
Wo? Hier?
Ne.
Wo will das updaten?
Hier.
Moment, ich hab's doch gerade eben installiert.
War das, war das eine ältere, ältere
Version in Winged oder wie?
Meine Güte.
Aber es war älter als Oktober.
Ja, ist glaube ich auch sinniger.
Hat aber immer noch,
hat aber immer noch, ähm,
Animations.
Wie man hier sieht.
Ich mein, besser als,
besser als nix.
Borders, bar.
Was hat man hier oben eigentlich?
Hier oben hat man
die Tray-Icons oder so.
Weil man hat jetzt, man hat jetzt unten
die Task-Leiste und oben
so eine Leiste.
Da fragt man sich natürlich,
für was ist das?
Da fragt man sich natürlich, wozu, ne?
Ja, das sind hier meine.
Ist das das, ist das
das USB-Icon oder wie?
Ok, die Leiste oben ist komplett
unsinnig, die braucht niemand.
OneDrive weg,
close, jawohl.
Das hier oben braucht, also,
dann verwende ich lieber die
Tray-Icons da unten, ganz ehrlich.
Wobei,
wobei es,
ja hier kann man Config neu laden,
aber das bringt ja überhaupt nix,
weil ich reloade die ja schon
mit Shift-Alt-R, habe ich die ganze Zeit
schon gemacht.
Das da oben braucht man anscheinend wirklich nur,
um Desktops anzuzwischen,
wie unter E3. Deswegen wäre es eigentlich
ganz gut, hätten sie es
irgendwie geschafft, das in die Task-Leiste zu
integrieren, die Anzeige vom Desktop,
dann bräuchte man diese Bar da oben nicht.
So ist das bisschen doppelt
gemoppelt irgendwie.
Falls, musst du in Anführungszeichen, ne,
muss nicht, muss hier oben ja auch nicht.
Ok, steht das auch ohne.
Oder meinst du ernsthaft,
ich soll, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ne, macht doch nix.
Windows-Taskleiste hat ein Desktop-Switch-Icon.
Moment,
ist denn? Moment!
Das sind keine Windows,
das sind keine Windows-Desktops
hier, die ich da sehe.
Das ist eigenes Windows-Handling.
Warte mal,
Task-View?
Guck, das sind keine Windows-Desktops.
Windows-Desktops
kann ich auch haben,
die sich aber
nicht switchen lassen mehr.
Dann, also ich kann jetzt
i3, ich kann den jetzt gestartet
haben auf jedem Desktop,
auf jedem
Windows-Desk, ok, das ist ein bisschen
zu abgedreht da, ne.
Oh, da kommt er durcheinander.
Da kommt er durcheinander, da blickt er immer durch.
Das ist,
das kann man nicht zusammenverwenden.
Das checkt er nicht mehr.
Aber das, ok, Windows-Desktops
darf man nicht verwenden.
Was aber schon ein bisschen doof ist,
dass das nicht mit Windows-Desktops implementiert ist.
Highlight active, inactive
Windows, component
left workspaces, ja, haben wir.
Component center,
Windows-Teil.
Ok, dass man sieht, was auf ist, ja.
Braucht man eigentlich
überhaupt gar nicht, hab ich unter i3 auch nicht.
Ah, guckt.
Was interessiert
mich, ob da oben steht,
welche Anwendung ich offen hab.
Ich seh's ja, ich hab sie direkt vor der Nase.
Ich verwende Windows-Desktops
immer, guckt zum Beispiel hierfür.
Zwischen, zwischen
vm und host.
System tray, ich weiß
immer noch nicht, was der Button da gemacht hat.
Also, die Leiste hier oben ist,
bis auf die Desktop-Anzeigen, eigentlich komplett
überflüssig.
Weil die Taskleiste ist ja auch noch da.
Und die Taskleiste wirst du wahrscheinlich auch brauchen.
Weil du willst ja vielleicht mal was anklicken hier,
was man da nicht unbedingt machen kann, rechts
und so. Also,
also ehrlich gesagt,
es wäre cool, als hätten die,
sie hätten die Desktop-Anzeige
als Overlay von der
Taskleiste gemacht.
Dann hätte man sich hier oben nämlich die Leiste sparen können.
Nee, ich, ich,
Taskleiste ausblenden bringt ja nix.
Du willst ja schon ab und zu mal
auf irgendwelche Sachen hier unten zugreifen, sei es
so Netzwerksettings, Sound-Lautstärke und sowas.
Das da oben
müsste eigentlich weg.
Und ganz ehrlich, das da oben kann
auch weg. Nur die
Desktop-Anzeige, worauf man ist, braucht man noch.
Vielleicht kann man, vielleicht kann man
die, ach guck mal, die Bar kann man auch
Bottom machen, vielleicht.
Ah nee, okay.
Die ist dann über, das ist,
ich, ich hab gehofft, die Overlay
die Taskleiste vielleicht.
Kann man die Bar Left
machen? Was eigentlich wenig Sinn
macht, aber.
Nee.
Warte mal, Top?
Leute, es ist
kaputt. Es reloaded.
Ich glaube, es ist gecrashed.
Ich glaube, es ist kaputt.
Es ist, es ist gecrashed.
Please.
Oh nee,
mein Tastatur-Layout ist geswitched
auf, ähm,
jetzt ist es wieder,
es ist wieder da.
Äh, was kann man sonst machen?
Okay, das konnte man
Bottom einstellen, das ging,
ne, ja.
Und dann konnte man was sagen? Offset.
Was macht denn Offset X?
Okay, ja, das ist so.
Und Offset Y?
Minus, minus?
Äh, bringt nix.
Das Overlay, leider nicht die
Taskleiste. Das könnte man
tatsächlich noch ganz gut gebrauchen.
Time-Format juckt nicht,
Workspace-Names.
Ignore-Screen-Clipping-Host.
Und
Task-Manager.
Okay, das funktioniert, Task-Manager floated
weiterhin, ganz gut.
Resize.
Da merkt man halt, dass man doch unter Windows ist,
ja, man kann Fenster resizen,
die dann halt einfach wieder groß gemacht werden,
weil man eigentlich nicht resizen darf.
Wenn ich das bei meinem
Linux-i3 probiere, dann
merkt man, dass
er macht entweder
gar nichts,
oder er resizet halt
den Split,
wie das aufgeteilt ist.
Und erst wenn ich das Floating mache, kann ich es richtig
resizen. Also hier einfach
resizen geht halt nicht.
Merkt man halt, dass das unter Windows nicht dafür gedacht ist.
Okay,
Resize-Key-Bindings.
Focus-Left, Focus-Right.
Ja.
Kann man auch hier, kann man zum Beispiel
jetzt auch Terminal aufmachen
und hier zwischendurch skippen.
Das finde ich ganz nice, das ist unter i3 auch
nice. Dann
Move-Windows.
Ja, das mache ich so gut wie nie, aber es geht ähnlich.
Shift-Alt-Left,
Shift-Alt-Right. Nur dass es halt
bei meinem i3 Windows-Taste ist,
anstatt Alt.
Sind die Animationen weg? Gute Frage.
Ja, die Animationen sind weg.
Außer der Task-Leiste.
Die Task-Leiste ist komplett am Ausflippen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Task-Leiste kackt komplett ab.
Oh.
Die Task-Leiste ist komplett am Abkacken.
Alt-U, Alt-P.
Achso, da kann man...
Okay, das mache ich
immer hiermit.
Bisschen laggy, aber das liegt bestimmt an der
VM, dass laggy ist.
So, dann haben wir noch
Tiling-Direction und so. Das benutze ich unter
i3 auch seltenst.
Ach, Alt-Shift-Q.
Das habe ich wohl Schlüsselstudio Code beendet.
Alt-Shift-Q.
Glace-VM-Alt-Shift-E.
Ist das gleiche. Reload-Config. Deswegen habe ich das
auch eben ohne Probleme gefunden.
Alt-Enter-Terminal.
Jo.
Focus the workspace. Okay.
Alt-1, 2,
3, 4, 5. Ja.
Übliche.
Das war's. Also ich finde das
gar nicht mal so übel.
Man muss halt sagen,
es integriert sich wirklich nicht so
sch... Ich sag doch, ich finde es
ganz gut, ne?
Jetzt starte ich Firefox und Firefox hat einfach keinen Bock
da drauf. Ah ja.
Okay, wenn man Firefox einmal
gesagt hat, du sollst es jetzt machen,
dann geht's auch.
Aber wenn man Firefox einfach...
Anscheinend hat sich das Firefox
gemerkt und mag jetzt doch.
Lass uns mal ein bisschen auf GitHub
gucken.
Schieben wir den Editor mal auf 2,
so wie ich das auch habe.
Also eigentlich habe ich Shell auf 2,
Editor auf 3
und unter Linux
Browser auf 1. Also hier haben wir
Browser, hier haben wir Shell, hier haben wir
Editor. Ja, passt so eigentlich ganz gut.
So, was kann man denn da jetzt
so alles machen noch? Download,
scoop, roadmap, full
roadmap. Okay, was haben die noch so
vor? Viel.
Issues gucken.
Ah.
Mehr Issues als der Fiat Champ.
Das ist immer ein gutes Zeichen.
Ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht...
Lass mich mal kurz checken,
wie viele Issues gibt's da? 23 immer noch.
Oh, da gibt's Pull Request.
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ihr seht, meine Open Source Projekte
sind super gepflegt.
23 Issues einfach
am Start.
Und keinen Bock irgendwas zu machen.
Ja, das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Ja, die Bar haben wir auch schon
konfiguriert, aber die Bar finde ich...
Die Bar finde ich
eigentlich total überflüssig. Die braucht man nicht.
Ich bin fast
geneigt, die Bar auszublenden.
Weil auf welchem Desktop ich bin,
weiß ich auch so.
Und der Platzverlust hier ist es eigentlich nicht
wert. Ja, Bar
Enabled eigentlich false.
Wo war das hier?
Mit der Bar?
Gibt das sowas?
Kann man die Bar
irgendwie...
Tastleiste ausblenden bringt überhaupt
nichts. Du brauchst
Tastleiste hier, wenn du mal irgendwelche Settings willst.
Wenn du mal die Lautstärke anpassen willst.
Dann lieber die andere Bar.
Also disablen
kann man das anscheinend nicht.
Ach doch!
Ich bin doch ganz fett da. Enable true.
Alter, erst mal...
Enable false.
Zack!
Nice!
Ja, so finde ich das deutlich angenehmer.
Ich weiß eh auf welchem Desktop
ich bin. Wisst ihr, unter meiner
Linux-VM
hat die Bar ja noch irgendwie einen Sinn.
Die zeigt mir nicht nur an, auf welchem Desktop
ich bin. Das ist ja schön und gut, das bräuchte
ich nicht unbedingt. Aber
hier habe ich ja meinen Tray
und so ein paar Infos über mein System.
Ob ich zum Beispiel so blöd war und hab
Numlock wieder gedrückt.
Diskusage.
Ich kann hier ein Timer
starten, wenn ich an was erinnert werden will.
Und CPU-Auslastung
kann ich hier oben mit meiner Bar auch
anzeigen. Finde ich übrigens extrem nice.
Guck mal.
Das sind die CPU-Kerne
hier oben, die angezeigt werden.
Das sehe ich, wenn ein Kern hängt. Wie verrückt.
Ich mach grad ein bisschen
random Terminal-Ausgabe.
Jetzt ist es wieder abgebrochen. Zack!
Das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Da sieht man immer, ob im Hintergrund irgendwas
brödelt. Also wir haben
glaube ich. Aha! Guck mal.
Da gibt es noch mehr Sachen für die
Bar. Man kann Batterie anzeigen lassen.
CPU-Usage,
GPU-Usage,
Memory-Usage, Network.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass Wetter
besser als die Windows-Wetteranzeige
wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
System Tray, das hatten wir schon.
Icons in Bar.
Ich fürchte fast, das ist schon alles, was man
damit machen kann.
Es ist wie bei i3. Bei i3 kannst du
ja auch nicht wirklich viel damit machen. Aber das ist
wahrscheinlich auch der einzige Grund,
warum ich i3 mag und alle
anderen Sachen auf dem Linux-Desktop eben nicht
mag. Weil i3
ist sehr
überschaubar. Leute, ich finde
das gar nicht so schlecht, muss ich ehrlich
sagen. Ich kann es nicht
unter Windows verwenden, weil
also ich würde es
normalerweise, würde ich es mal ausprobieren.
So einfach, wie es sich anfühlt, mal ein paar
Tage das zu benutzen.
Aber ich kann es nicht verwenden, weil ich muss auf der Arbeit
Windows verwenden und wenn ich mich
an die Bedienung von einem Tiling-Window-Manager
unter Windows gewöhne, dann kann ich mein normales
Windows und umgedreht. Das funktioniert nicht.
Wo ist jetzt der Vorteil
zum normalen Desktop?
Ja, dass es einfach angenehmer ist
mit der Tastatur zu bedienen.
Ja, du weißt immer, hier hast du
deinen Browser, hier hast du deinen Terminal, hier hast du
deinen Editor. Was eigentlich
ohne Scheiß 90% der Sachen
sind, die ich brauche.
Unter Windows
ist es ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich
der Browser. Man könnte
jetzt Steam starten und sowas hier drauf noch,
aber das könnte ich dann
tatsächlich auf den eigenen Desktop
oder so. Ich finde es gar nicht mal so
doof. Wobei man halt
auch mal ehrlich sagen muss,
der Vorteil
versus, also ich
habe ja hier eh, ich habe drei Anwendungen
im Fullscreen auf aktuell.
Der Vorteil
versus Windows-Desktops
ist es eigentlich nicht wert.
Ja.
Ja, meine ich. Aber guck, ich kann
auch Windows-Desktops wechseln
und ich habe hier, ne,
also erster, erster, zweiter, dritter. Das ist vielleicht
nicht so nice, wie bei
i3 mit dem Durchswitchen. Und wenn man
dann doch mal teilen
muss, ist es auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Aber so wie ich das hier benutze
mit drei Fenstern im Fullscreen,
dafür reicht
auch die eingebaute Windows-Desktop
Switch-Funktion.
Gibt das hier, was ist das?
Comorebi.
Teilen Windows Manager vor
Windows PS.
PowerShell oder was?
Moment, ist das ein komplettes PowerShell-Ding?
Oh! Leute!
Wisst ihr,
was ich da sehe?
Was sehe ich denn da?
Es ist blazingly fast!
Die
Krustentiere sind am Start!
Blazingly fast, written in Rust.
Das
Left-WM. Das ist aber nicht
für Windows, oder? Das ist
für, oder?
Das ist für Linux, oder?
Oder, steht da Windows?
Ne, ne, das ist für Linux
hier. Und das ist wahrscheinlich,
so wie ich mir vorstelle, Wayland-Only?
Ach ne, es ist
SSX. Also
so obsolet. Naja, es
funktioniert halt, ne?
Und warum sollte man beispielsweise das verwenden,
anstatt das I3, wo wir
gerade dabei sind? Also, weil
es blazingly fast, written in Rust ist, oder
wie? Und das ist
Überzeugung. Das ist quasi
überzeugend genug, written in Rust.
Wie war die
Tastenkombi bei Windows für Switchen?
Ähm,
Control, Windows-Taste und dann
Pfeiltaste links, rechts.
Why go left? Okay.
Is it Tiling? Okay, wenn
die erste Begründung schon ist,
warum man es benutzen solle,
weil es ein Tiling-Window-Manager
written in Rust ist,
das wäre für mich eines der letzten
Begründungen überhaupt, in welcher Sprache
man Window-Manager geschrieben hat. Okay, sagen wir mal
so, ähm,
wenn es Java wäre, würde ich
es wahrscheinlich erst gar nicht ausprobieren.
Stable and performant.
Ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt, also ich glaube, i3
hat nicht, bei ihnen auf den
Fahnen stehen, Performance.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, noch nicht einen Fall,
dass i3 jemals, wirklich
jemals geleckt hat.
i3 macht halt einfach auch nichts,
wo es irgendwie lecken könnte.
Es hat keine Animationen,
das hat nix,
i3 kann nix, i3 macht nix,
deswegen mag ich i3.
Die haben doch bestimmt irgendwie
ein Issue, warum man das anstelle
von i3 verwenden soll.
Ähm,
den kenn ich nicht,
aber der ist written in
Rust, das ist natürlich noch viel geiler.
Das probieren wir jetzt auch noch aus.
Komorebi.
Also dann beenden wir
Glace mal.
Oh, es beendet, jetzt wie?
Komorebi.
Äh, Moment, wo ist er?
GitHub. Ach,
Chat, wirklich, ja?
X11 geht,
Blackscreen lag an Wayland.
Wie ich fast schon vermutet habe,
ja?
Oh, hier kriegen wir das gezeigt.
Wir probieren das jetzt selbst aus.
Komorebi.
Overrated-Projekt.
Dann downloaden wir das mal.
MSE.
Vom Julius.
Ist halb...
Ja, Leute,
wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Wir kompilieren das
unter Windows from scratch.
Das wird jetzt was.
Build from source.
Okay, wie installiert man Rust
unter Windows?
Kann das Winget?
Winget. Search.
Rust.
Rustup ist der Version-Manager, gell?
Macht sogar Sinn.
Okay, Winget.
Winget. Install.
Rustup.
Ich find's auch ein bisschen doof,
dass man weiß nirgends,
wo das herkommt. Wie wär's mit einem Projekt-Link?
So.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal die richtige Stelle.
So, jetzt wird erstmal 3000 Sachen
installiert, so wie das bei Rust
üblich ist.
Das ist ein Rust-Projekt aus 700
Dependency-Cargo-Dependencies.
Cargo-Packages.
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Winget. Info. Rust. Up.
Ne, natürlich nicht.
Rust.
Okay, da muss ich bestimmt neu starten. Ne, das funktioniert.
Da ist es doch!
Cargo. Nice!
Schon haben wir's am Start.
Jetzt muss ich noch... Winget. Install.
Shit. Ne, haben wir nicht.
Git.git muss ich
installieren. Okay.
Git for Windows. Oh ne, das ist mit dieser komischen
Git-Bash-Shell und sowas.
Ganz ekliges Zeug.
So, Building. Oh!
Ist das etwa ein Window-Manager für Weebs?
Hab ich das grad richtig gesehen? Naja, fast.
Wo ist der
Sebaro? Okay, Building
from Source wollte ich mir angucken.
Building from
Source.
And then clone this repo and compile
the source code to install the binaries for code.
Okay.
Die zwei Sachen muss ich machen anscheinend.
Paste. Ach, Quatsch.
Ich hab's ja immer geklont.
Ja, das stimmt. Code.
Clone. Git.
Das ist ja, Windows ist ja nicht in der Lage, das zu reloaden.
Jetzt. Git.
Jawohl. Git.
Clone.
Alter, das Pflaster am Finger nervt mich.
C.
Mogibi.
Nee, da steht einfach
ich muss
Da steht drinnen, ich muss das repo klonen.
Ah, die Readme, man, die
macht mich fertig.
Da steht, ich muss das
Die hab ich, die hab ich doch.
Und jetzt
machen wir einfach sowas hier.
Dann sollte es gehen.
Was macht minus minus locked?
Doch, doch.
Also Rust ist nicht ganz so schlimm wie Node.js, aber
ihr seht es ja hier.
Moment, was brauche ich alles?
Link.
Not found.
Ah ja.
Bildtools muss ich installieren.
Bildtools
von Microsoft Visual Studio.
Was auch immer ich da gerade
installiere.
Eigentlich will ich nur
die Bildtools installieren.
Peter von Microsoft
Support.
Microsoft Gold Partner Support.
Äh.
Hä?
Einfach sagen install jetzt?
Übrigens an diesem UI-Installer
seht ihr, dass Microsoft ihre eigene UI-Technologie
nicht verwendet. Ich glaube, der ist nämlich in
Elektron, der Installer, oder?
Launch. Was passiert, wenn ich Bildtools
launche?
Okay, es geht eine Shell auf. Na toll.
Da wären wir nie drauf gekommen.
Äh.
Okay, das hat bestimmt wieder nicht
geladen. Link.
Äh. Das geht nicht.
Muss ich das hier drüber
starten?
Link.exe.
Nö.
Oh, Moment.
Bildtools von Visual Studio install with
Visual C++ Option.
Habe ich das gemacht?
Modify.
Muss ich das da machen?
Wow.
Alter. Was lädt
da alles runter?
Und, und was?
Und was muss ich? Hier.
Bildtools.
Alter, Windows. Das ist doch alles.
Man kann jetzt übrigens auch nicht mal hier neben ausklappen.
Das muss.
Das auch?
Nee, PowerShell neu starten hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe ja sogar die Bildtools gestartet,
aber das gibt es da nicht.
Guck.
Reicht das, wenn ich so installiere?
Einfach so?
Reicht so?
Modify. Jetzt musst du einfach nochmal 6
Gigabyte runterladen, man.
Du kannst das separate.
Also, ich weiß schon,
warum ich seit Jahren
nichts mehr unter Windows entwickle.
Okay.
Es ist C++. C++
ist pauschal eh immer kacke.
Ich bemittle halt alle
Unreal Entwickler.
Wobei ich glaube, Unreal
verwendet einfach den ganzen
C++ Bullshit
nicht und hat viel
eigenes drumherum gestrickt.
Wir bauen überhaupt nicht den 4Champ
neu. Heute hat schlicht und ergreifend niemand
angepasst.
Ist meine Zeitzone falsch? Kann das sein?
Ich glaube,
wir haben nämlich 21.33 Uhr.
Chat Gil.
Oder?
Mal aufs Handy gucken.
Ja, wir haben 21.33 Uhr.
Was macht der da
eigentlich gerade?
Ah, der ist fertig mit Downloaden.
Der installiert jetzt.
Installing Package
105 auf
271.
Alter. Okay, wie macht man
denn die Zeitzone hier richtig?
Mal gucken, ob ich das wenigstens finde.
Adjust Date and Time.
Time Zone. Okay.
Amsterdam, Berlin.
Okay, wenigstens
funktioniert sowas unter Windows halbwegs brauchbar.
Was macht der da eigentlich gerade?
Ist der immer noch am Installieren?
Oh, der installiert das Windows 10 SDK.
Das ist bestimmt ein bisschen
größer. Mal kurz den
Task Manager gucken, was der da treibt.
Windows Update?
Ich checke nie, was da im Hintergrund
passiert.
Wisst ihr, das mag ich unter Linux auch.
Da machst du Top oder H-Top oder
B-Top oder B-Dingsbums.
Eines der 15.000
Top-Klone
Dinge auf und siehst, welcher
Prozess da was
macht. Du siehst, mit welchen
Parametern der gestartet wurde.
Du kannst dir auch meistens was drunter
vorstellen. Unter
Windows brauchst du Zusatzdinger.
Selbst im Prozessexplorer weißt du oftmals
nicht, was es ist.
Guck mal ernsthaft. Du guckst hier bei Windows
rein und du siehst dann so Dinger
wie...
Prozessexplorer.
Laden wir mal runter.
Download.
Runterladen. Prozessexplorer.
Zip.
Run.
Akkriege.
Soskei Akkriege.
Sortieren wir mal nach CPU Last.
Also erstens guck mal, wie viel
krasses Zeug da schon läuft.
Dann hast du so Dinger. Du weißt halt immer
nicht, was es ist.
Unter Windows.
Smartscreen. Da weißt du, das ist irgendein Antivirus.
Da hast du so Dinger wie hier
der TI
TI-Worker-Echse. Ja. Oh Gott. Nice.
Alles klar.
Okay, das ist VMware.
Trusted Installer.
Ganz viel SV Host
Echse.
SE Host.
Security
und Health Systray.
Wisst ihr, du hast unter Windows
dreimal Runtime Broker.
Du hast unter Windows so viel Zeug, denn
du hast so viel Zeug.
Du hast so viel Zeug.